Hey youtubers it’s charlie.
Doctor Who Week Continues with my list of
top 5 Doctors.
My friends and I have been doing a bunch of
special videos to celebrate the 50th anniversary
this week so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
We’re even doing a special livestream and
I’ve also got some special news about something
I’m doing on the BBC America television
channel.
So let’s get started, my number 5 favorite
doctor - Peter Davison the fifth doctor.
So he had the unfortunate task of following
up Tom Baker who’s also on this list.
In order to differentiate himself his Doctor
became this really charming and sensitive
person.
Think of it as being like the jump from the
more mature Tennant to a slightly less silly
Matt Smith.
His doctor was also the first to directly
oppose violence and always came up with much
more creative ways to solve problems.
io9 actually ranked his final episode the
Caves of Androzani as the greatest doctor
who story of all time.
Number 4 - Matt Smith, the eleventh doctor.
So just like Peter Davison, Smith had to follow
an incredibly popular doctor who is also on
this list.
He really won me over with his boundless enthusiasm.
All of time and space, where do you want to
go.
And with Stephen moffat at the helm they introduced
a lot of really new aspects of the doctor’s
life that we’d never seen before.
Namely River Song, the fields of trenzalore
and now the john hurt doctor.
Smith’s run also helped popularize doctor
who in the united states in a way that hadn’t
been done before.
Previously Doctor Who had a strong cult following
here, but now the show reaches a much larger
audience.
My Favorite Matt Smith episode is definitely
the doctor’s wife. because he may have married
river song.
But he married the tardis first or the tardis
married him.
depending on how you look at it.
Number 3 - Christopher eccleston, the Ninth
doctor.
He’s most famous for regenerating Doctor
Who in such a new and complex way.
His Doctor was damaged by war and had to live
with the guilt of essentially dooming his
entire race to time prison.
But he also had this fun adventurous spark
and it was so amazing to watch him jump back
and forth between those extremes.
Of all the doctors, he was also one of the
most imposing.
According to River Song the Doctor is the
most fearsome man in all of time and space.
And eccleston had this largeness and intensity
that really made you believe it.
My favorite Christopher Eccleston episode
was Rose, because that was the episode that
brought the series back.
Number 2 - Tom Baker, the fourth Doctor.
Even though Four had the benefit of being
on the classic show at the height of it’s
popularity, there were so many good writers
and the best companion the show has ever had.
And then there is the scarf.
If you’ve ever been to a cosplay convention
then you’ve seen the scarf.
Even if you’re not familiar with doctor
who you recognize the scarf.
Baker had this really goofy but witty sense
about him that made you feel like the doctor
was taking himself far less seriously than
during the third doctor’s more action-heroey
run.
Without it feeling like
a parody of itself.
Part of me feels like some of that comedy
survived the regeneration into Matt Smith’s
doctor.
My favorite Tom Baker episode is City Of Death.
It was written by Douglas Adams under the
name David Agnew which itself became a legend
of doctor who.
The episode was one of the great classic who
epics where the style, the story and the cast
come together in the best possible way.
And my number 1 Doctor.
David Tennant, the 10th doctor.
So many things changed about the character
and the show in general during Tennant’s
run that I feel like he deserves his spot
here.
Just to give you an idea of how much he grew
doctor who’s audience, the BBC had to shorten
their broadcast window.
That’s the time between when an episode
airs and when it airs in other countries.
Because so many people in international countries
were downloading it The BBC fundamentally
altered the way in which they broadcast the
show around the world.
This week for instance the BBC is airing the
50th anniversary episode in every country
at the exact same moment for this very reason.
Tennant had this amazing commitment to the
role that allowed him to go from this lighthearted
sweet man and turn on a dime to All powerful.
“He’s like fire and ice and rage.” that
came from tennant.
My favorite David Tennant episode is Blink.
Because weeping angels.
The idea that a stone statue could get you
when you’re not looking at it.
And a girl getting help from an alien time
traveler who’s leaving her clues in the
form of DVD easter eggs.
Stephen Moffat also won two awards for the
story.
All I can say is that you need to buy the
DVD of the 50th Anniversary episode and watch.all.of.the.extras.for.clues.
But since everyone experiences Doctor Who
in their own way let me know who your top
5 doctors are in the comments below.
Tomorrow I’ll be posting my review of an
adventure in space and time.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll also have more details on what other
bonus videos are coming this weekend.
Don’t forget, we’re doing a livestream
pre-show for the 50th this saturday starting
at 2:30PM pacific time.
It will be on BBC America’s youtube channel.
Watch it, because my face will be there.
Right now click on one of these annotations
to watch the awesome doctor who week videos
my friends are making.
Thanks so much for watching.
see you guys tomorrow, high fives!